emmanuelle cosse la secrétaire nationale
d'europe écologie les verts est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
là pour votre première participation à
ce rendez vous de public sénat avec l'
agence france-presse et dailymotion
qu'at-elle prigent de la fp et puis
perrine tarneaud de public sénat nous
rejoindrons tour à tour pour aborder
bien sur les questions d'environnement
sur lesquels les verts d'ailleurs ne
font pas si entendre leur voix selon
certains même selon certains de vos amis
et pourtant entre le traumatisme de
fukushima il est tout juste trois ans et
la pollution aux particules fines dans
nos villes il ya beaucoup à dire et à
faire évidemment et puis vous êtes là
également pour parler de vous aussi
votre engagement militant
jusqu'aujourd'hui a suivi plusieurs
détours nous en parlerons tout à l'heure
d'abord le climat politique qui se tend
sur fond d'affaires et d'écoutés
judiciaires de l'ancien chef de l'état à
soupçon soupçons et demi puisque la
droite ne crois pas au hasard
est-ce que tout est bon pour empêcher le
retour de nicolas sarkozy en 2017
écoutez moi je crois que c'est pas ça le
sujet le sujet c'est on apprend
aujourd'hui qu'il ya des écoutes
téléphoniques dans le cadre d'une
enquête qui touche l'ancien chef d'état
qui touche un avocat et la question est
de savoir pourquoi pourquoi elles ont
lieu à ce qu'elle respecte le droit mais
pour savoir ça il faudrait contexte le
dossier il connaît pas le dossier
il faut bien le dire les écoutes y
compris sur un avocat sont possibles
dans un cadre très limité et avec des
réquisitions très strictes qui sont
encadrées par le code civil et c'est
normal parce que c'est normal qu'on
puisse pas écouté comme ça que n'importe
comment quelqu'un qui à l'action du
secret professionnel
les avocats s'insurgent vous fait réagir
sur l'environnement malin de leur part
parce que de fait on parle pas du vrai
dossier
la question que moi je me pose et j'ai
pas la réponse mais personne ne l'a
c'est pourquoi il dit enquête
qu'est ce qu'il a dans cette enquête
qu'est ce qui a justifié qu'on fasse des
excuses qu'elle suspicions portent sur
nicolas sarkozy voir son avocat
et j'imagine que si un moment un juge a
estimé qu'il avait besoin de poursuivre
ces écoutes téléphoniques et depuis un
an c'est pour des raisons suffisamment
solide pour le faire nous sommes dans
une démocratie dans un état de droit et
il me semble que nous avons des
magistrats qui
agissant en connaissance de cause après
que des avocats soulève la question de
savoir si leur profession et le secret
professionnel est respectée ils ont
raison de le faire mais la réalité il
faut être très honnête il n'y a que les
magistrats qui sont en charge de cette
affaire qui ont la réponse
et je ne crois pas jusqu'à preuve du
contraire qu'ils vont prendre la parole
actuellement sur le sujet bien
évidemment mais vous avez raison
effectivement emmanuelle cosse de
rappeler qu'on ne sait pas ce qu'il ya
dans le dossier des juges d'instruction
mais vous dites quand même il peut y
avoir une suspicion légitime de la part
des juges qui enquêtent est ce que vous
êtes étonnés par exemple que nicolas
sarkozy et son avocat est acheté des
téléphones pour se parler discrètement
écoutez c'est leur pratique moi j'ai pas
à les juger simplement on apprend ça
aujourd'hui mais moi je vais pas rentrer
dans la dans le commentaire de ces
questions là aujourd'hui il arrive ça
comme en 2008 on a appris qu'on avait
écouté un journaliste du monde dans le
cadre d'affaires et on a vu ensuite
comment avaient été diligentées sait
écouter de manière totalement abusive
est ce qu'il ya un procès sur les soirs
des fadettes du monde donc si je dis ça
c'est que il s'agit pas de commenter la
l'histoire ou pas il ya une enquête qui
est des magistrats qui travaille à un
code pénal un code civil dans notre
république et la question de savoir si
les respecter ou pas et si l'état de
droit est ce que vous écoutez en tous
les cas les juges d'instruction ont agi
à bon escient jeudi en tout cas que rien
ne permet aujourd'hui de dire qu'ils ne
l'auraient pas fait et moi jusqu'à
preuve du contraire je fais quand même
confiance aux magistrats dans ce pays
mais après je comprends le malaise que
ça peut susciter avec les avocats et en
général
comment est ce que vous qualifiez ce ce
climat général de retour d affaires au
premier plan mais en tout cas elle pas
beau mais en même temps
il n'arrive pas là juste par hasard et
moi l'histoire
attention on a entendu des proches de
nicolas sarkozy par exemple presque dire
ceci
il laisse fortement entendre que tout ça
n'est pas dû au hasard et il laisse
entendre que le pouvoir en fait utilise
la justice contre nicolas sanhes
faudrait un peu arrêter ces histoires là
moi je pense qu'à un moment il ya des
enquêtes et qui sont diligentées c'est
parce qu'il ya des soupçons de pratiques
frauduleuses 1 et au l'histoire conte à
15 jours des municipales est ce que vous
croyez vraiment que les français
actuellement c'est le seul incident
pendant les municipales
moi je les vois distribuer des tracts
comme beaucoup de personnalités
politiques en ce moment il nous parle de
questions d'emploi de logement de savoir
s'ils vont se nourrir leurs enfants à la
fin du mois mais ce que je dis derrière
c'est que quand arrive la sphère sarkozy
quand vous êtes en pleine enquête sur
l'histoire de corbeil essonnes et avec
serge dassault et d'autres sujets c'est
que quand même il y a aujourd'hui des
soupçons d'affaires et donc je trouve
normal que la justice se fasse qu'elles
se fassent dans un climat serein qu'on
ne soit pas sa descente sur les soupçons
de faire je dis simplement ce que je dis
c'est que c'est l'effet qu'ils sont
comme ça aujourd'hui vous avez des
enquêtes des gardes à vue et des choses
qui arrivent
les perquisitions de patrick buisson
harry aujourd'hui parce qu'il y en a
quatre qui ce qui est lié à ces sondages
qu'il ya depuis pas mal de temps donc il
ya un certain nombre de sujets qui
arrive aujourd'hui comme ça moi je ne
vais pas regretter que des magistrats
face à travail y compris pour innocenter
des gens s'ils le font on dit comme
brice hortefeux mais pas pour les mêmes
raisons ça n'est pas dû au hasard peut
même même jamais et simplement ce que je
dis c'est que quand il ya des enquêtes
au contraire on devrait estimer qu'il
faut que cette enquête ait lieu pour y
compris faire la part du vrai du faux
selon vous le pouvoir l'elysée la
chancellerie pouvait-il ignorer la mise
sur écoute de l'ancien président la
réalité c'est que d'un point de vue
légal
oui ils peuvent totalement ignorée mais
dans la réalité puisque le canard
enchaîné à paraître donc jeudi explique
qu'en fait à la fois à christiane
taubira mais également manuel valls
avait été prévenu fin février de 7 mille
soucis judiciaires de l'ancien chef de
l'état ni ni officier de police
judiciaire ni magistrats ni avocate donc
objectivement j'ai aucun moyen de le
savoir
je pense que des choses peuvent être
dites mla la réalité c'est pour ne le
sais pas en tout cas la loi le code
civil et le code pénal n'impose pas que
le garde des sceaux soient au courant
dans ce type d' enquête et c'est tout à
fait normal que ce soit
regardez les sceaux a demandé au
procureur fin janvier de lui faire
remonter toutes les affaires sensibles
elle a demandé notamment faire plus
sensibles se situent leur a demandé de
faire inventer l'ensemble des affaires
médiatiques notamment je pense pour ne
pas aller mais sans fil est ce que cela
a été fait je ne sais pas comment est ce
que vous interprétez la phrase récente
de françois hollande qui étaient
rapportés par le journal du dimanche
c'était tout à fait récemment devant des
députés socialistes
il a dit nicolas sarkozy je le surveille
je sais exactement ce qu'il fait écoutez
je sais pas parce que je ne suis pas non
plus député socialiste donc je ne
commande pas les discussions j'ai france
aux gens que je ne suis pas non mais
sincèrement est-ce que vous redoutez ce
climat un peu du tous pourris qui sera
forcément préjudiciable à tous les
partis de gouvernement et profitable à
l'extrême droite
ce qui est certain c'est qu'aujourd'hui
il ya une défiance de la politique et du
personnel politique qui seront en parle
mais c'est pas qu'il ya des histoires de
d'affaires c'est aussi pourquoi est ce
que c'est la même personne qui se
présente depuis 40 ans dans sa commune
pourquoi il n'y a pas de renouvellement
pourquoi est-ce qu'on en assemblée
nationale si peu paritaire est si peu
représentée tsd diversité de notre
société
ces sujets là qu'on nous pose
aujourd'hui et après vous avez raison
qu'il peut y avoir des soupçons qui sont
liées à des pratiques à des affaires ou
un manque de transparence et de ce
côté-là la fac à lusaka porter un coup
fatal
je le dis franchement vous avez un
ministre qui dit je crois que c'était
quoi droit dans les yeux je jure que est
en fait après doit admettre qu'il avait
un compte en suisse c'est quelque chose
qui nuit à la démocratie
vous ressentez une forme de nausées non
mais moi non non non non mais la
question c'est est auditeur pression
c'est plus loin des partis politiques
médecins slick de pratique mais plus de
transparence dans leurs pratiques mais
aussi qu'on combatte cette idée de tous
courir parce que faut aussi arrêter avec
ça s'engager en politique s'engager dans
des mandats
ça demande un investissement majeur un
choix est souvent au détriment d'une vie
professionnelle et un engagement pour
les gens quand vous êtes maire d'une
petite commune c'est pas pour votre aura
personnelle c'est parce que vous voulez
vous mettre au service d'une communauté
et je le dis parce que il faut aussi
arrêter de constamment y compris dans
les médias penser que le personnel
politique c'est des gens qui font
carrière qui font ça pour les ors de la
république
la réalité c'est très souvent on fait ça
plus tôt par conviction est que
justement entre parenthèses
notre carrière professionnelle et
l'absence de notre vie et je crois aussi
qu'il faut saluer ses engagements là
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est quand on
souffre et on l'a vu pour les
municipales ça m'avait beaucoup de gens
qui n'ose pas s'engager en politique
n'ose pas s'engager pour des
responsabilités parce qu'ils ont peur de
la confrontation ils ont peur des
difficultés administratives et c'est ça
qui peut nuire à la promo sur les
avocats donc ils se mobilisent à vous
avez vu de toutes tendances d'europe
comme gauche contre 500 pour la 156 me
les ténors vont avoir les avocats
j'étais jury j'ai beaucoup d'amis avocat
donc pour moi les avocats c'est pas
juste les ténors c'est à mon sens deux
avocats comme prix des grattes papiers
qui travaillent dans l'ombre alors
parlons de ceux qui se mobilisent pour
l'instant ils le font contre la mise en
danger estime t-il de leur profession
alors ils ne réclament pas de l'immunité
bien sûr mais il dénonçant que ceux de
ce1 danger commun pour la démocratie
dans cette atteinte à leur secret
professionnel est ce qu'il faut par
exemple un nouveau texte de loi pour
mieux encadrer les écoutes dans qui les
concernent écoutez l'histoire des
écoutes téléphoniques ça toujours été un
sujet important en matière de respect
des droits et libertés a commencé mais
ses collages et oui mais même ça a
commencé dès 1992 avec un arrêt de la
cour de cassation ça me et des pratiques
anciennes qui avait été très loin là
dessus après aujourd'hui je pense qu'on
a fait la part des choses et que c'est
bien encadré
néanmoins je pense que remettre
constamment en débat ce sujet là et
s'assurer que l'exercice du métier
d'avocat elle secret professionnel sont
sauvegardés me semble nécessaire mais je
vous le dis le problème c'est qu'on peut
pas se mobiliser juste à l'aune de ce
cas dont on ne connaît pas le contenu
regardons plutôt comment la loi s'exerce
aujourd'hui elio la discussion
collective entre avocats je pense
le ministère de l'intérieur et le
ministère de la justice pour discuter de
ça et voir aussi si nous respectons sur
tout l'ensemble des dispositions de la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme qu'il faut une commission d'
enquête sur ces écoutes comme le
demandent par exemple françois fillon
moi je pense surtout il faudrait plutôt
des commission denquête sur certaines
pratiques dont on parle surfacturation
micro partis et tous ces sujets là des
sujets de la transparence de la vie
politique
ah bon c'est chacun se renvoie c'est
prenant
en débat à l'assemblée au sénat sur la
question de la vie politique notamment
la question des micro partis moi je me
souviens que jean françois copé était
contre la suppression des micro partis
ainsi qu'une grande partie de l'ump même
temps celui qui en profitent c'est
jean-françois quand vous demandez une
commission d enquête sur les surfaces il
faut faire les commissions dans le cadre
travaillant plus tôt sur la question de
l'exercice de la vie politique de la
transparence et aussi parce qu'il faut
aussi le dire que s'il y avait dans
notre pays un vrai statut d'all eu un
véritable statut d'élu avec véritable
indemnités correctes des régimes
indemnitaires correct est beaucoup mieux
arrêter
je pense qu'on serait moins dans ce
système là est-ce qu'il faut convoquer
le parlement en session extraordinaire
comme le réclame d'autres à l'ump qui se
mobilisent un certain matisse le climat
la stasi en france
je crois qu'il faut que chacun garde aux
raisons et reste un peu calme sur le
sujet alors vous ne voulez pas lier
l'émergence de ces climats à l'après
présidentielle oui parce que 2010 était
dans toutes les têtes seulement à gauche
aussi on entendu dimanche claude
bartolone le président de l'assemblée
nationale
suggérer aux verts de ne pas présenter
de candidat à côté de françois hollande
et contre françois hollande qu'est ce
que vous pensez de cette idée est ce que
vous devez faire l'impasse
je vais vous dire c'est les écologistes
qui choisiront ce qu'ils font sur la
présidentielle et c'est pas les
socialistes la patronne conçu et ensuite
claude bartelone son idée développée
depuis plusieurs mois même je pense
depuis deux ans d'être aussi
certainement mais ce débat là se posera
à l'aune de 2015 2016 nous verrons bien
jusque là nous avons toujours présenter
un candidat ou une candidate à
l'élection précédente en réponse un
c'est trop tôt et deuxièmement pour dire
les choses très franchement nous ce que
nous souhaitons c'est qu'il écologie à
la présidentielle même si c'est pas une
élection dans laquelle nous croyons avec
un candidat forcément de l'écologie la
question nous avons bien moi
personnellement je pense qu' il vaut
mieux avoir des candidats pour défendre
ses positions mais je ne vous dis pas
que ce sera la position du parti que
c'est votre position elle comptait
l'abordons mais la vitesse qu'ils font
qu'il ya un candidat la gambie la
question c'est où peut-être la question
c'est qu'est ce que le parti voudra
faire à l'aune de ses capacités et de
comment il sortira la situation parce
qu'il ya une difficulté dans la dans
l'élection présidentielle c'est que vous
êtes finalement dans une élection où en
fait très tribunicienne où n'existe que
deux ou trois ténors et la question
c'est comment vous portez un projet
comment vous
mais y compris dans d'autres sélections
avec dominique voynet avant même ma mère
c'est toujours des combats très
difficile pour nous avec une difficulté
après assemblée pour le contre don vous
êtes plutôt pour vous nous l'avez dit il
nous faut regarder comme un candidat
quand vous les rumeurs de remaniement
s'intensifie et jean marc ayrault
d'ailleurs semble pencher pour un
gouvernement resserré où est ce que vous
voyez cécile duflot dans un nouveau
gouvernement après le logement et moi
j'ai eu n'importe où à mais plus haut on
va bien surtout je sais pas mais bercy
premier ministre non premier ministre
mais la réalité
je vous pensais que je souffrais mais la
réalité c'est que je ne sais pas ce que
veut faire françois hollande avec son
prochain gouvernement nous attendons
comme vous des rumeurs de remaniement
elles sont dans tous les sens en termes
de noms de personnes en termes de
volonté en terme d'affichage
la question c'est que si françois
hollande veut continuer des écologistes
qui nous disent ce qu'elles projet et
qui nous c'est pas une question de
personne résultat son c'est la
présentation des parties qui fait dire à
françois hollande tu prends untel ou
untel communiste parce que je ne pense
pas que ce soit à matignon ce serait
donc le départ de jean marc était
absolument en capacité de tenir des
grands ministères y compris sur des
sujets majeurs notamment les questions
que nous lui en est à envisager quand
même le remplacement de jean-marc
ayrault à matignon est ce que vous
estimez qu'il est définitivement
pénalisé par sa défense de l'aéroport
notre dame non mais c'est pas c'est pas
le sujet déjà moi j'en ai trouvé
extrêmement bien avec lui et je pense
que c'est un premier ministre qui par
ailleurs est très engagée sur le sujet
et d'un dialogue et des écologistes
objectivement je n'ai aucun problème de
pluie et même parfois je regrette que
les socialistes ne soutiennent pas plus
et après la question on a un conflit
entre nous qui est la question n'est pas
de l'or mais qui n'est pas une question
gouvernementale
et puis j'en ai jamais fait l'alpha et
l'oméga de discussion que jean marc
ayrault qu'on voit c'est pas un sujet et
compresse je vais vous dire la
personnalité du premier ministre qui
sera ce n'est pas mon sujet la question
c'est que veut faire françois hollande
et son premier ministre sa première
ministre qu'est ce qu'il veut faire pour
la france qui propose pour les trois
années qui viennent
l environnement environnementale est en
général comment
les les sa victoire de dénis quelques
ajustements va maintenant aborder
d'autres aspects politiques et ces
questions d'environnement avec katell
prigent de l' agence france-presse
d'abord cette interrogation qui parcourt
aussi certains de vos amis je vous le
disais tout à l'heure les verts au
gouvernement font-ils vraiment avancer
la cause écologique
mounir souci les verts auraient ils
perdu de leurs couleurs dans la machine
du pouvoir plusieurs élus et militants
le pense
daniel cohn bendit avait déjà pris du
champ fin 2012 et ces derniers mois deux
députés ont claqué la porte du parti
excédé par le renoncement du
gouvernement
noël mamère et isabella tard ont rendu
leur car nous sommes dans une situation
telle que partir ou rester c'est qu'il
faut à peu près à la même chose nous
sommes dans une impasse parce que nous
avons avalé tellement de couleuvres
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes complètement
déconsidéré par de maltraitance de la
question de l'écologie et de
l'environnement par le gouvernement
actuel
oui c'est sûr c'est une évidence entre
le recul sur l'écotaxe l'abandon d'une
taxation du diesel et la prolongation de
la durée de vie de la centrale de
fessenheim les déceptions sont
nombreuses pourtant les verts n'ont pas
rompu avec le gouvernement se
concentrant sur d'autres sujets pour
peser dans la majorité
les écologistes verts au départ sont
devenus plus rouges que verts et donc
ont un peu abandonné l'ombre nettement
abandonné le combat écologique comme
s'il n'y croyait plus ou comme si le nid
se sentaient impuissants et donc ils
sont allés sur des sujets sociaux un
virage mal compris par la base et les
militants de la cause écologique
allain bougrain dubourg défendent est la
nature avant la création des verts il se
dit déçu par l'orientation actuelle est
averti ce glissement est avant tout
dangereux pour le parti lui-même le
discours politique que l'on entend est
en décalage total me semble-t-il avec
les racines environnementale je trouve
ça dommage parce que ils se coupent de
leurs racines et donc ils perdent des
soutiens potentiels je le vois dans la
vie associative environnementale qui
n'est plus en phase avec les verts un
décalage qui pourrait se payer dans les
urnes aux européennes cette élection
avait installé le parti au premier plan
en 2009
depuis de nombreuses figures se sont
éloignés ce scrutin test révélera si les
électeurs sont aussi tentés de prendre
le large
voilà qu'apple présente avec nous vos
questions sont nombreuses
alors est-ce que l'exercice du pouvoir
vous a fait perdre beaucoup leur passé
un peu plus du rouge perdre du verre je
crois pas je j'entends ce qui peut être
dit et notamment c'est vrai qu'avec les
débats incessants sur que faites-vous
gouvernement quand est ce que vous allez
partir qu'en fait la seule chose qui me
posent en général dans les médias on a
un peu tendance à plus parler de ce
sujet écolo fondamentaux et y compris et
ça je le reconnais leur élection
présidentielle n'a pas mis assez avancé
ces sujets là moi même je les regrettés
et d'autres dans le parti donc je
reconnais aisément ce sujet là que nous
n'avons pas su en tout cas en 2012 met
les questions écolo environnementale au
coeur du sujet politique pour nous comme
on l'avait fait pour les régionales ou
pour les européennes avant mais après
sur la question du sujet moi je regarde
ce que font part de nos parlementaires
et je veux bien qu'on dise qu'on
s'occupe pas d'écologie mais jusqu'à
preuve du contraire qui travaille sur
les pesticides ces noms sur
l'aménagement du territoire c'est nous
sur la question de la pollution de l'air
c'est nous y compris pour échouer sur la
question du design et nous continuerons
qui écoute et or est très claire on a
dix-sept parlementaires isabella tard
nous a quittés pour nouvelle donne mais
reste dans notre groupe
parce qu'elle n'a pas non plus d'autres
assises et par ailleurs je rappelle
qu'elle a été élue dans un accord
vps ensuite noël mamère en effet à
quitter europe ecologie les verts et en
même temps est présent à nos côtés dans
l'ensemble notre campagne électorale des
européennes
donc moi je veux bien qu'on regarde ça à
l'aune de ces deux personnes sauf que la
réalité c'est que moi je regarde ce que
fait notre groupe parlementaire à
l'assemblée ce qui fausse sénat et
jusqu'à preuve du contraire les grandes
réalisations actuellement 100 sur des
sujets écolos y compris la commission d'
enquête sur le coût du nucléaire
donc on peut toujours passer notre temps
à reprocher aux écologistes ne pas faire
assez d'écologie et dans ce cas là quoi
aussi qu'on accepte de donner une
tribune pour ne parler que de ces sujets
là etc et c'est bien et c'est bien le
sujet ce qui est certain néanmois c'est
qu'aujourd'hui dans la société
il ya une envie de débat on le voit très
bien compris dans les municipales on a
besoin de débattre sur la pollution de
l'air sur la question de l'écologie au
quotidien sur commencé à s'alimenter de
manière notamment du bio des aliments
moins polluer sans dépenser l'ensemble
de ces sa fortune français des sujets
qui reviennent
et en effet on a besoin d'y répondre
collectivement des sujets qui ont un
écho dans la population l'écologie
avance au niveau de la société comment
vous expliquez que ça n'avance pas
l'écologie politique c'est à dire que
vous en tant que groupe politique au
final ça continue à bloquer en tout cas
je pense que c'est vrai qu'on n'arrive
pas à être en tout cas dans certaines
élections notamment la dernière
présidentielle à être au niveau de la
houle n'avions pas y compris dans les
villes et c'est pour ça que les
municipales je vois bien que l'accueil
est très différent alors il ya deux
choses il ya d'une part les questions
des modes de scrutin qui nous enferment
objectivement dans un métier qui ne
correspond pas à ce qu'on a vu nous
portons ou dans la société c'est pas
pour rien que les européennes depuis le
début que les verts existent et d'une
élection besoin des bons scores
je parle même pas du score de 2009 même
avant nous a toujours des 10% 9% à 11%
donc c'est pas anodin dans le paysage
politique et ensuite c'était aussi de
notre part une difficulté à construire
notre vision sur la durée pour plusieurs
raisons d'une part on est un petit parti
comme moins d'expérience que des partis
qui existent bien depuis bien plus
longtemps que nous et aussi je pense une
exercice du pouvoir et des
responsabilités qui est aussi moins loin
que nous que d'autres partis mais en
même temps nous faire nous travaillons
là cieux nous progressons beaucoup et je
pense aussi ce qui est difficile pour
les écologistes c'est que quand vous
battez beaucoup très longtemps sur un
sujet je prends la pollution de l'air la
question de la pollution de l'air
aujourd'hui dans une ville comme paris
n'importe qui reconnaît qu'il ya un
problème avec la position de lars était
bon on est en pleine alerte
vous êtes en pleine alerte pourquoi
parce que depuis des années vous avez eu
un moment des écologistes concret
airparif qu'ont trouvé les subventions
concret une loi qui met en place les
alertes qui ont mis en système une
transparence explique ce que je vais
vous dire c'est que on est aussi nous
sur des combats ça fait 25 ans qu'on est
là dessus et c'est aussi très durs comme
étant des combats de la sorte sur une
très longue durée d'arrivée ensuite à
être connu pour ça et aujourd'hui vous
avez raison sur la pollution de l'air il
faut que maintenant on arrive et que et
le gouvernement et les gilles est
véritablement des propositions pour
permettre de réduire le trafic
automobile dans ces épisodes la de
pollution très forte
vous parliez de votre jeunesse dans
l'exercice du pouvoir est ce que
justement votre partenariat avec le ps
ne vous et fasse parce que le ps ne vous
connaissent pas par exemple lorsque vous
parle de taxe voilà le passé pour des
taxes heures quand même les écologistes
à chaque fois et le ps s'arrange
toujours pour que le message écolo passe
derrière et redevienne une tactique
politique vous à vous avez raison si
vous faites allusion à l'épisode sur le
diesel même pas tendre taxe carbone mais
l'histoire du diesel avec le débat sur
la loi de finances 2014 l'an passé où il
est certain que cazenave a été bien plus
malin clos sauf que nous on désarme pas
et la question c'est que moi je veux
bien que le gouvernement continue dans
son aveuglement sur la question du
diesel en dise on n'y touche pas parce
que beaucoup de français ou un véhicule
diesel
sauf que jour où le gouvernement sera
poursuivi par ces mêmes français parce
qu ils ne supporteront plus les coûts de
dépenses liées à l'or maladies
respiratoires à cause du diesel d'un
seul qu'on aura gouvernement qui sera
obligé d'agir en urgence donc donc ne
désarment pas on apprend aussi nos
erreurs et je sais qu'un et projet n'en
fera autrement
une présence à bercy donc non mais c'est
un sujet fondamental faire la transition
écologique et énergétique vous l'a fait
en changeant aussi les leviers fiscaux
et des leviers économiques et en plus je
pense que la société est d'accord avec
ça simplement il faut pas lui imposer le
problème sur le diesel c'est que il
s'agit pas dire on coupe tout de suite
la niche fiscale sur le diesel et demain
vous pourrez les
diesel au même prix que les sens enfin
que le sans plomb 95
on peut pas dire ça à des gens qui à un
moment ont fait un choix économique par
contre on peut leur dire d'ici dix ans
on va totalement réduire parce qu'il
faut absolument sortir de cette
incitation qui grave pour notre santé on
va vous aider soit à changer de véhicule
soit à l'utiliser mois soit à être aidés
sont vos déplacements et c'est ça le
sujet c'est comment vous donné
pratiquement à nos citoyens des
solutions pour sortir de cette situation
ils soient en otage on vous dit vous ne
désarmez pas effectivement il ya la loi
de la transition énergétique qui
approche vous aviez dit que ça pouvait
être un motif de rupture est sorti du
gouvernement ça l'est toujours son vous
attendez de quoi exactement
et quels sont les motifs qui vous ferait
sortir du gouvernement ce qui nous y
attend une loi ambitieuse qui acte un
changement de modèle énergétique qui
soit vraiment un tournant de la france
sur la question énergétique
ça passe par une réduction de la part du
nucléaire et en saas et l'engagement
présidentiel de passer 75% à 50% de la
part du nucléaire dans la production
électrique
ça passe par un plan de financement et
de développement des énergies
renouvelables avec une aide
véritablement à la filière aux
entreprises des énergies renouvelables
et donc ça exige aussi des
investissements importants et enfin ça
passe par des mesures sur la question de
l'efficacité énergétique et de la baisse
de consommation et aujourd'hui il ya un
sujet majeur celle et les économies que
nous pouvons faire en rénovant des
logements et les bâtiments publics
c'est un enjeu majeur il ya aussi des
sujets sur la question des transports et
tout ça et sur le nucléaire
le patron l'atome a encore un avenir
pour vous non non non non mais c'est
arnaud montebourg dit le contraire oui
et si vous avez remarqué que le
gouvernement se transforme en vrp
comptant dix réacteurs qui sont en
construction dans le monde parce que la
france que ne pas participer à ces
contrats vous savez la france vient de
voir deux paires à la grande bretagne
sauf que pour que la france arrive enfin
areva arrive à vendre ses 2 op r il a
fallu qu'elle qu'elle assure un tarif
d'achat d'électricité à 110 euros
quand l'éolien grande bretagne est à 49
euros donc ça veut dire c'est ça la
vérité sur le nucléaire
la vérité sur le nucléaire c'est que 1 3
ans après fukushima on voit bien que
personne dans le monde n'est capable de
répondre à une catastrophe nucléaire sur
comment est-ce qu'on peut réparer
et arrêter dit contaminé les
investissements supplémentaires ddf 10
milliards de plus pour la sûreté
mais beaucoup plus edf aujourd'hui on
est à 55 milliards d'investissements
pour faire ce qu'ils appellent le grand
carénage sauf que la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui nous dit serait plutôt
3,5 milliards qu'il faudrait mettre et
par ailleurs on peut parler aussi de
flamanville le fabuleux e p r de
flamanville toujours pas fini de
construire un budget 4 ea play est un
des pères où il ya des malfaçons en
pagaille
c'est pas les écologistes anti
nucléaires qui vous dit ça c'est
l'autorité de sûreté du nucléaire
la question c'est que nous ne sommes pas
non plus des gens complètement farfelu
nous sommes opposés au nucléaire du fait
des dangers que représente le nucléaire
pour notre population et la planète mais
nous savons bien qu'on va pas fermer
l'ensemble des centrales du jour au
lendemain
la question c'est comment vous engager
le pays vers une sortie du nucléaire en
actant des fermetures notamment des
centrales les plus fragiles et comment
vous avez une reconversion y compris des
personnes qui travaillent dans le
nucléaire mais c'est quelqu'un travaille
de longue haleine c'est aussi un travail
sur l'énergie renouvelable et là dessus
nous sommes très simple et je sais
qu'aux six jours la fermeture on a
l'impression que fessenheim
on vous a promis une fermeture qui a
l'air quand même de l'avenir qui ne
viendra pas si elle viendra et elle sera
actuelle sera faite à quelques elle crée
à fessenheim notamment une opposition
très fort dès compris de salariés qui
est moi je le reconnais on a un travail
très exigeant très compliqué plus il
faut comprendre le stress que connaît
des salariés du nucléaire qui vivent
dans un questions de sûreté très
difficile mais elle sera arrêtée
fessionnels la question s'est passé avec
moi je vais vous dire le vrai sujet
c'est les autres centrales d'ailleurs et
c'est pas 2016 c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
fait d'ici 2025
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour un ensemble de
centrales dont aujourd'hui l'autorité de
sûreté du nucléaire nous dit si vous
devez les prolonger il va falloir faire
tant de milliards de travaux dessus est
ce que c'est ça l'intérêt de la france
est ce que c'est ça ou de l'argent
public doit être utilisé ou est-ce qu'on
doit décider y compris edf s'engage
beaucoup plus fortement sur les marchés
des énergies renouvelables et gagne des
parts de marché sur le sujet parce qu on
est patron d'edf
vrai ministre de l'écologie ou non j'ai
entendu cette phrase par une ancienne
ministre de l'écologie mais
objectivement je pense que philippe
martin décide avec jean marc ayrault
dessous ce qu'il a à faire
est ce que pour être plus audible
justement être reprendre de la couleur
verte qu'il faudrait que vous ayez le
ministère de l'écologie à ce qui est
certain c'est que le fait de ne pas
l'avoir moi je pense que nous handicape
y compris sur un grand nombre de sujets
qui sont notamment les questions de
pollution de l'armée de l'eau la
question de la biodiversité et plus
généralement mais je dis ça je ne sais
pas pour quelle raison ils ont fait ces
choix là nous avons eu plusieurs
ministres à ce poste-là
ces tracés 18 mois dernier qui ont fait
le choix d'être quand même très timide
dans la médiatiser s'était réjoui que
pour une fois les écologistes n'est pas
l'écologie puisse exercer dans bach
n'existait pas autant je comprends le
pari nous l'avons fait aussi dans les
régions d'avoir des vice-présidences sur
des sujets autres que les sujets
classiques et fondamentaux de l'écologie
de l'environnement autant moi je pense
qu'au niveau national
être à la tête de ce ministère est
fondamentale donc on va surveiller de
très près évidemment votre vote sur ce
texte de transition énergétique mais le
gouvernement jean marc ayrault
particulièrement vous attend sur un
autre texte
c'est celui du pacte de responsabilité
la leaf est une condition évidemment du
matière de la majorité dans énormément
allez vous voter le barrage comme vous
le savez il n'y aura pas de texte sur le
pacte donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on
arrête aussi de dire tout et n'importe
quoi considérer qu'il soit voté au mois
d'avril
non il n'y aura pas de test sur le pacte
il y aura un vote de confiance à l'issue
d'un débat de politique générale sur un
renfort objectivement c'est pas la même
chose je veux dire par là que le pacte
il faut dire les choses très franchement
qu'est-ce quoi qu'on en pense
le pal de responsabilité ne va pas se
traduire par un texte de loi
il vaut mieux se traduire en partie par
des dispositions dans la loi de finances
à venir et en partie dans des accords de
branche
donc on fait un débat sur la question
savoir qui va voter y compris ce que les
communistes ont voté ou tout ça mais
l'arrêter s'il n'y a pas de texte
l'autre sujet c'est la confiance et moi
il me semble qu'en effet quand on est
dans une majorité ont voté la confiance
après je pense aussi que jean marc
ayrault va aussi y mettre l'ensemble des
projets qu'il a annoncées pour l'année à
venir la décentralisation la fin de vie
les questions de la transition
énergétique et d'autre
sujet donc il ya ça et puis après il ya
tout le débat sur l'assurance 2015 avec
un sujet important qui connaît notre la
ciotat commission si la confiance au
peuple annonce en tout cas reste ce
n'est pas moi qui vais le dire vous
savez il n'y a pas de mandat impératif
dans les parties donc c'est dans les
jolis très franchement ça nous députés
qui décideront d'un groupe parlementaire
et même les sénateurs n'ont pas leur mot
à dire là dessus
le dernier mot car oui vous parliez des
municipales il y en a un qui a compris
qu'il y avait un problème de couleur
effectivement si jean luc mélenchon qui
essayait de récupérer évidemment marqué
ici alors une alliance avec le pg
écoutez j'écoute avec amusement et en
même temps sympathie les déclarations de
jean luc mélenchon mais la réalité c'est
que laquelle les écologistes sont des
choix locaux sur les élections
municipales dans beaucoup d'endroits en
autonomie dans beaucoup d'endroits en
avec le pianiste et dans quelques
endroits on est avec le parti de gauche
pour des raisons de local à grenoble
notamment à rennes notamment ou à
lorient avec le front de gauche y
compris que le parti communiste c'est
des sujets locaux on a choisi de faire
enquête
ensemble pour une municipalité il faut
aussi être très clair c'est pas la base
c'est pas là dessus que construit des
alliances politiques sur un sujet
national
merci quel est le prix jean perrin
internautes public sénat arrive
maintenant pour parler de vous avec vous
d'abord lé enquête sur votre itinéraire
militants avec julien cholin 30 novembre
emmanuelle cosse succède à cécile duflot
à la tête d'europe écologie les verts
même style même décontraction même
manière de s'adresser aux militants
même sourire aussi et pourtant de
parcours bien différents emmanuel coste
fait ses armes dans le milieu associatif
elle s'engage contre le sida au sein
d'act up en 99
elle prend les rênes de l'association
c'est donc une femme qui est élu à sa
tête une femme hétérosexuelle des
séronégatives un combat pour la vie dans
une organisation réputée intransigeante
il ya pas vraiment de changement parce
que justement je participe et déjà
l'association pas mal de temps donc
c'est que toi une continuité dans la
radicalité dans un combat de fond en
même temps conditions de méthodes un peu
radical et un peu violente s'en suit une
carrière de journaliste au magazine têtu
d'abord puis comme rédactrice en chef de
la revue regards ses confrères se
souviennent d'une femme ancrée à gauche
mais pas particulièrement écologique
elle et quand elle était ici elle
n'était pas à fond pour europe ecologie
les verts
et comme elle n'était pas à fond pour le
front gauche a été à fond pour que y ait
un point de vue de gauche qui prévalent
dans la politique en 2010 cécile duflot
lui offre une place sur sa liste aux
régionales
emmanuelle cosse accepte le défi et
prend sa carte aux écolos elle va là où
ça bouge là où on lui propose de faire
des choses le front de gauche n'a pas
proposé de faire d'être sur sa liste aux
régionales europe écologie les verts l'a
fait elle y est allé et elle a fait sa
place finalement il n'aura fallu que
quatre ans à l'ancien d'act up pour
prendre la tête des écologistes au sein
du parti certains la décrivent sûre
d'elle et ambitieuse caroline mécary
siège à ses côtés au conseil régional
quand on est à la tête d'un parti on
doit être un même à la fois d'avoir de
l'empathie pour chacun des membres de ce
parti ou de manière à pouvoir rassembler
faire consensus autour de soi donc si en
effet on est dans une position qui à
certains moments peut être perçu comme
étant du roucas hantent ce n'est me
semble-t-il pas une bonne manière de
pouvoir mener un parti politique
déterminé et pragmatique ambitieuse
voire autoritaire pour certains
reste à voir si dans les prochains
chapitres et mac os rejoindra sa
prédécesseure dans les plus hautes
sphères de l'état et mac os donc parce
qu'on vous appelle comme ça entre
militants et satan c'est un peu sévère
un certain de vos proches là on va en
parler
pas vraiment des proches alors périment
soir et mac os déjà sur la comparaison
avec cécile duflot c'est vrai que tous
les portraits qui sont sortis sur vous
après votre élection à la tête des verts
y avait toujours cette comparaison qui
revenait avec cécile duflot vous la
comprenez elle vous étonne elle vous
énerve
je la trouve assez inutile enfin si
c'est juste parce qu'on est brune et
qu'on a les cheveux longs
non mais je le dis sincèrement parce que
je trouve ça un peu facile et un peu
idiot c'est qu'on a voulu parler de
proximus réducteur par rapport au fait
que vous êtes dans un parti politique et
voilà vous faites des choses ensemble et
c'est bon ça brûle succède à une autre
femme brune
oui il ya eu un homme mon twitter
c'était quand même parce que
l'environnement mais faut dire aussi les
choses telles qu'elles sont campus -
cécile gelé connu pendant les régionales
c'est quelqu'un que je ne connaissais
pas avant avait conclu dans ma vie
militante alors que je connaissais plein
de verre depuis très très longtemps donc
je le dis avec beaucoup de facilité et
ensuite je suis toujours un peu étonné
que quand on parle des femmes qui
s'investissent en politique c'est
toujours sur à qui elle ressemble et
d'où elle vient et c'est qu'ils sont
entourage je le dis parce que on fait
peu ça des hommes qui arrive y compris
je pense qu'elle aime désir on n'a pas
gardé si ressembler à son sa
prédécesseure quoi vous l'avez pas
entendu on vous l'avait pas attendu en
plus cécile duflot pour vous engager en
politique et surtout dans les
associations on l'a dit dans le
reportage a fait vingt ans que vous
militez vous avez presque une longueur
d'avancé face sur elle vous avez
commencé à militer qu à l époque je
n'avais pas du tout le même parcours
c'est vrai que moi je me suis engagé
très jeune j'avais 17 ans act up qui
était suspendu contre le sida en 1992
dans une période où quand même on
mourait du sida ou y avait qu une seule
molécule sur le marché il faut repenser
à ça c'est important de le dire pour des
gens qui est en fait était pas née tout
simplement à l'époque est dans une
période où on parlait très peu de ces
questions de santé
on avait beaucoup de discrimination ou y
compris dans la communauté homosexuelle
a décrit très très forte
il n'y avait pas de contrat d'union
sociale on parlait pas de ces sujets là
dans les médias
il y avait beaucoup de discrimination
des gens qui sont retrouvés à la rue
c'était ça quand même histoire les
années 90 et c'est pas anodin y'avait
acteurs il y avait en même temps le
mouvement sur les laissant droit à la
question des sans logis avec notamment
la création du dal qui était une période
quand même sociale très forte et c'est
vrai que je me suis engagé là dedans
dans les années 90 en parallèle de mes
études et que je me suis retrouvé un mou
un jour présidente parce que les choses
se sont faites comme ça mais c'était un
engagement en plus absolument vital pour
moi et l'engagement en politique il
était naturel derrière tout ça il
n'était pas si simple
pour tout vous dire quand j'étais act up
avec beaucoup de camarades d'act up on a
toujours pensé que pour peser
pour pouvoir avoir des avancées
législatives pour améliorer la question
des droits il fallait qu'on essaie de
rentrer dans des postes à
responsabilités et y compris d'avoir des
connexions que les partis politiques
voire de se présenter à des élections
on voulait se présenter à la
présidentielle de 95 législatif de 97
ans on avait théorisé ces choses-là
après c'était impossible à faire pour
des raisons y compris technique parce
que ça s'invente pas doit être un parti
politique ou tout ça mais en même temps
pendant très longtemps j'ai pas eu un
fils dans un parti politique
j'avais des amis qui étaient y compris
des amis qui étaient chez les verts et
je regardais ça avec intérêt en même
temps ce n'était pas ce à quoi j'aspire
à l'époque mais j'ai toujours regardé ça
aussi avec intérêt
pas avec envie mais avec intérêt parce
qu'il me semble que dans les partis
politiques dans les gens qui s'engagent
et quand même des gens qui veulent faire
avancer les choses et qu'ils sont là
aussi pour répondre aux besoins de la
société
certains disent que vous avez renier
votre engagement militant pour une
ambition politique pour le pouvoir
politique n'est pas vraiment pas pour
tout vous dire les choses quand s'est
créé europe écologie au même moment
secret le front de gauche il ya une
recomposition dont l'ensemble de cette
gauche et c'est vrai que vous avez
hésité entre les deux formes et angers
pas hésité moi j'étais à l'époque
rédactrice en chef de regards qui est un
journal fait par les communistes
fondateur antilibérale qui revenait
l'expérience des comités anti libéraux
suite au débat sur le tc eux le traité
européen
j'ai regardé ça avec intérêt gst depuis
très longtemps dans le milieu associatif
dans des mobilisations et un moment vous
vous dites aussi est-ce que j'ai pas
envie de faire autre chose autrement dit
à caroline mécary convoi dans le sujet
elle a aussi cette réflexion là quand
ils arrivent au régional en même temps
quatre heures elle est avocate a été
très engagée dans les combats pour les
homosexuels elle se dit est-ce que je
dois pas aussi agir autrement parce qu'à
un moment vous pouvez aussi avoir envie
d'agir autrement
et pour tout vous dire moi j'ai regardé
avec intérêt ce qui se passait dans
cette gauche c'est au gré d'un point de
vue journalistique mais aussi d'un point
de vue personnel
et puis il ya les européennes de 2009
pour europe écologie avec une volonté
réelle et pas simplement fait de mots de
s'ouvrir et de réunir les écologistes
moi j'ai toujours voté écolo s'est
toujours senti très proche de cette
fibre environnementale
contrairement à ce que pouvaient dire
peut-être la directrice de regard un
sujet
un peu disait catherine mais c'est aussi
parce que c'était pas vraiment le sujet
de mes fonctions à regarder j'ai
toujours été engagés ce sujet là j'ai
toujours voté écolo mais en même temps
un moment je ne savais pas si c'était
intéressant ou pas d'aller dans le parti
il s'est passé les européennes et
mâchant pas lors des discussions avec
yannick jadot notamment moss et
christophe nadjovski que notre candidat
aujourd'hui à paris qui me disaient mais
que je connaisse qui devait vient c'est
intéressant
il ya de quoi faire c'est un parti on
peut faire des choses on peut faire sa
place et c'est comme ça que je suis
arrivé les historiens pendant quatre ans
pour à la tête des verts en quatre ans
j'avais l'impression de voir tomber en
plus bouger vous dire sincèrement je ne
vis pas comme ça et je vis pas cette
histoire comme ça comprenez qu'on puisse
vous taxe est judicieuse je comprends
mais comme vin le rouleau compresseur en
gamme et en même temps je vais vous dire
on a parlé de moi je sais que je
travaille je suis engagé je crois dans
le coin mais à mon engagement mais en
même temps sincèrement en fait c'est
vraiment pas mon ambition autant je vais
vous dire les choses quand j'étais à
octobre ses prévisions mais juste pour
finir ma france quand j'étais acteur
j'étais très ambitieuse pour vraiment
avoir des gains sur la question du sida
quand je suis devenue vice présidente en
charge du logement la région ile de
france
c'est vrai que mon ambition a été de me
dire mon mandat doit être utile je dois
arriver à aider au mieux la construction
de logements sociaux et sortir les gens
des marchands de sommeil sur l'île de
france avec mes moyens je dois
développer ça donc de l'ambition j'en ai
aujourd'hui comment comment mieux servir
vos cause demain alors votre ambition
c'est quoi à moi mon ambition
aujourd'hui c'est de porter mon parti
est objectivement vous dire qu'on
réussisse à d'échéances électorales et
qu'on réussisse aussi parce qu'on en
parlait tout à l'heure notamment à mieux
porter nos fondamentaux et nos idées et
notamment sur les questions
environnementales et sur les questions
et collomb ne le dit pas ce que c'est ça
l'idée quand vous êtes écolo quand vous
vous vivez dans cette dimension là c'est
pas toujours évident parce qu'on est
aussi beaucoup rails et beaucoup moqué
qu'on a aussi un parti qui donne une
image de lui qui est pas toujours la
meilleure
objectivement je recherchais le
consensus à tout prix
non c'est pas le consensus la question
c'est que c'est d'une part l'action et
je pense que ça c'est très important
pour un parti de pas être que dans le
commentaire mais d'être dans l'action et
ensuite de gagner
moi je cache pas les choses on a échoué
sur notre élection présidentielle quand
vous êtes militant politique que vous
échouez élections présidentielles nous
avec un ce camp qui est faible où le ps
qui rate élections de 2001 vous le savez
très bien
c'est très dur de se remettre en
question de repartir de reconstruire des
choses mais moi je crois beaucoup à
l'écologie et j'ai envie que ça avance
j'ai envie que ça avance dans mon parti
j'ai envie que ça avance dans la société
j'ai envie que ça avance dans l'ensemble
des partis par ailleurs parce que ça
serait moins d'eau de convaincre les
autres s'ils avaient plus écologiste
dans l'ensemble des partis mécaniquement
parce qu'on voit bien qu'à telle fusion
vous a posé la question tout à l'heure
le message d'europe écologie ee est un
petit peu brouillé aujourd'hui notamment
vis-à-vis non seulement de vos électeurs
mais également des militants verts sur
le terrain qui seront perturbés par une
participation au gouvernement
écoutez les la réalité quand vous
regardez notamment des enquêtes faites
auprès de nos électeurs c'est qu'ils
sont pas du tout perturbé vous avez 75
points essentiels 15% de nos électeurs
aujourd'hui sont pour la participation
au gouvernement
la question qui veulent comprendre à
quel prix ils veulent comprendre surtout
pourquoi est ce qu'on y est et ce
qu'elle sujet on se bat et là où vous
avez raison c'est qu'avoir une cohérence
dans la parole politique constamment
faire de la pédagogie sur nos sujets ne
pas se laisser enfermer sur des mots
comme la taxe m'expliquer pourquoi on
veut avancer c'est ça mon ambition est
l'ambition c'est aussi qu'on arrive à
prendre le pas de grand combat écolo
c'est pour faire preuve de dureté on a
entendu là un témoignage d'autoritarisme
quand on dirige un parti non il faut
prendre des décisions ce qui est pas
exactement la même chose
c'est ça le plus tranché je sais tranché
je sais prendre les décisions et pas
toute seule je sais les prendre avec les
instances de mon parti
quand on doit les prendre mais le pire
pour un parti c'est de dire je ne sais
pas si je suis à gauche
si je suis à droite aussi chaud au
milieu c'est ça le sujet après moi je
vous dis moi je c'est vrai que je suis
relativement je ne dissimule pas les
choses je dis aussi les choses
franchement c'est pas être cash c'est
simplement qu'à un moment je pense qu'il
fait mieux
il vaut mieux non mais je ne le crois
pas il vaut mieux dire les choses y
compris sous lever les malentendus y
compris avec des gens
partenaires ou des gens avec qui vous
avez des conflits pour avancer et on
peut faire ça en étant dans la douceur
et dans l'explication dans le dialogue
parce que moi c'est vrai que je souffre
je n'aime pas les faux semblants je
n'aime pas d'hypocrisie et en plus je
pense que c'est du temps perdu et ça
c'est aussi ce que j'ai vécu avec act up
c'est que j'ai aussi appris parce qu'on
n'a pas beaucoup de temps
quand vous avez des camarades qui vont
qui sont malades et quel temps sont
engagés vous apprenez aussi aller plus
vite sur les choses et aller à
l'essentiel et g c'est aussi important
en politique juste pour finir emmanuelle
cosse
on en était très présent salon de
l'agriculture on entendu le gouvernement
parlait beaucoup des os des ogm de
seconde génération que le gouvernement
souhaite développer
est ce que j'ai entendu beaucoup de
choses au salon de l'agriculture j'ai
aussi entendu beaucoup de choses sur la
défaillance gm seconde génération nam et
les ogm je pense que c'est un débat
c'est pas un bon débat aujourd'hui je
sais qu'il ya des volontés de le
réouvrir j'ai encore vu des gens de
réouvrir sur la question de la recherche
j'ai aussi vu m'a beaucoup de gens qui
étaient très engagées contre salon de
l'agriculture est qu'aujourd'hui soulève
la question de savoir qui ne la survie
du modèle agricole français compris la
discussion ça n'a pas d'avenir pour des
ogm de seconde génération
je ne crois qu'il y aurait fallu le
rideau
moi j'en ai longuement discuté avec avec
josé bové qui est je pense et je crois
qu'il a raison qu'en fait c'est une
farce c'est effectivement on se souvient
des pressions spectaculaire des coups
d'éclat contre les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques sans si vous croyez sur
le sénat n'en croyez aux progrès de la
science
et je crois absolument produit les mêmes
sur l'histoire des médicaments s'est pas
c'est pas la science pour la science et
le problème dans ce débat sur les ogm
comme sur d'autres sujets c'est qu'on ne
dit jamais quels sont les effets des
recherches qui sont entreprises merci
d'avoir été avec nous mendel causse
merci merci perrine la semaine prochaine
pierre laurent qui occupe la même
fonction vous mais au parti communiste
français sera notre invité bonsoir et à
très vite